[Musique]
les moments inoubliables de l'enfance
sont des contes de fées
et dans le mien mon père était le
principe
[Musique]
au fait chier
on va aller habiter avec papa et des
chaussures votre épée regard signoret
[Musique]
comme valeur mamour ton avis à la barre
il a laissé avec deux gosses et morand
jenifer c'est juste des amis
je t'aime ma chérie tous les deux en est
fait du même bois nos coeurs sont
pareils
papa tu fais quoi
je suis entrepreneur
tempère est un menteur
il faut qu'on se parle franchement tous
les
je veux étudier le journalisme ans
quel genre de genève
l'investigation peut-être
pourquoi avoir menti sur votre
candidature
jules innocent jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on a décidé que j'avais aucun
droit
votre père john bogle à imprimer 22
millions de dollars
6e tout un monde explose et je serai là
tu zappes tes côtés
[Musique]